people were saying that he's being
targeted I'm like well let's look into
it and then I looked into it and
apparently a journalist took it upon
herself to contact these women and be
like do you want to be in a story about
Russell do you want to accuse Russell
Brand do you want to and like ask these
people to come out and I don't know if
this is 100 I haven't like been able to
confirm or deny because I don't know the
behind the scenes workings but it sounds
like it was a reporter that kind of put
all this together I just wanna I wanna I
wanna say uh I'll say two quick things
because we we got some great messages in
the chat uh this is uh um amtru said
that he said you said it to him they're
going to go after lawyers for doing
nothing next to be media personalities
yeah I didn't think this would be like
in relation to j6 right I didn't mean
like someone like Russell Brand I meant
people who are actively promoting j6 but
I do want to say this is modern
assassination
the way they the way they target people
uh uh powerful Elites corrupt
individuals mafias whatever back in the
day was assassination